Do you have any thoughts on the signature test? I thought I read that it picks up
remaining circulating tumor cells that are dead from the original tumor.
Well, the signature test is picking up DNA, circulated tumor DNA. Is it picking up dead
to circulate tumor cells? No, not to my knowledge. It's picking up circulated tumor cells that
to circulate tumor cells that are not dead. Is that a good thing to measure?
Well, some people use it as a measurement of whether the person is doing better or worse,
so they're doing a signature test. The measure, if the person has a decrease in
circulated tumor cells, then the practitioner may interpret that by saying the patient is doing
better. If they have an increase in circulated tumor cells, the practitioner may interpret that
as the patient is doing worse. However, if you really think about the physiology of that,
to me, that doesn't quite, and the reason it isn't because a cancer doesn't give off,
there's no data that says a cancer gives out more circulated tumor cells when it has, as it's
growing. There's times that it gives off more circulated tumor cells, but it doesn't necessarily,
it's not a one-to-one equation that the cancer is growing, nor is it a one-to-one correlation that
a decrease in circulated tumor cells mean the cancer is dying. So I don't see value in doing
the signature test because the data, it's just confusing. It doesn't give us adequate data to say
the person is doing better or worse. Again, you do a test if it's giving you data on how you're
going to change the treatment of the patient. If it's not giving you adequate data,
objectively whether the person is doing better or worse or needs a change in the treatment plan
that I don't see any value in spedding the money and running the test. That's why I don't run that test.
So that's my opinion. I don't think it's adequate objective data that would, that would warn it be
changing the treatment plan on a patient.